vamos al problema 116 116 en este
problema nos piden determinar el valor
de a más ve al cuadrado a más b elevado
al cuadrado en el inciso 1 de
información lo que nos dan es que el
producto ave ave es igual a 0
esto no va a ser suficiente para
determinar además b al cuadrado pues
simplemente nos dice que alguno de ellos
es 0 entonces esta información pues no
va a ser útil vamos a necesitar obtener
más información
de hecho déjame desarrollar este binomio
al cuadrado como al cuadrado más 2 veces
avn más b al cuadrado esto nos ayuda un
poco más a entender lo que está
sucediendo si sabemos qué ave es igual a
cero únicamente sabemos que este término
es igual a cero pero nos quedaría algo
del estilo a cuadrada más b cuadrada que
todavía no sabemos cuánto vale bueno
entonces el inciso 1 no es suficiente
para responder esta pregunta vamos a ver
qué dice el inciso 2
en el inciso 2 nos dicen que a menos b a
b elevado al cuadrado es igual a 36 a
ver pensemos que quiere decir esto
esto quiere decir que a menos b es igual
a 6 oa menos 6 a menos b es igual a 6 oa
menos ve a menos b es igual a menos 6
creo que esto de todas formas no nos
dice gran cosa verdad si sabemos la
resta de a&b pues no tendríamos porqué
conocer su suma y menos pues pudiéramos
elevar su suma al cuadrado entonces este
inciso por si mismo tampoco nos da mucha
información pero a lo mejor combinado
con el primero combinado con el primero
ya podemos responder la pregunta vale
entonces vamos a combinarlo y también
vamos a suponer que a x b es igual a 0 y
además déjame desarrollar esto de acá
estoy acá es una resta al cuadrado que
nos quedaría el primero al cuadrado
menos dos veces el primero por el
segundo más el segundo al cuadrado ok
entonces observa si sabemos que a b es
igual a cero entonces sabemos que este
término es cero entonces sabemos que a
cuadrada más b cuadrada es igual a 36
pero a cuadrada más b cuadrada era justo
lo que estábamos buscando al suponer que
a b era igual a cero entonces combinando
estos dos incisos podemos llegar a la
conclusión de que además b al cuadrado
es igual a 36 es igual a 36 y para
entender un poquito más lo que está
pasando vamos a hacerlo
vamos a aprovechar esto de que sabemos
que a menos de 6 y a menos vez menos 6
observa si sabemos estas dos cosas y
sabemos que a b es igual a cero entonces
algunos de ellos dos tienen que ser cero
y el otro tiene que ser seis o menos
seis entonces a y b son cero
y 6 en algún orden o bien 0 y menos 6 en
algún orden y por lo tanto al hacer su
suma nos queda o bien 6 o bien menos 6
pero luego estamos elevando esa suma al
cuadrado y por eso nos queda 36 vale no
importa si era 6 o menos 6 nos queda 36
a lo mejor esta última explicación ya
estuvo un poquito de más pero siempre es
bueno ver los problemas desde varias
perspectivas para poder entenderlo es un
poquito más a fondo va bueno vamos a
pasar ahora al problema 117 117
en este problema tenemos una figura así
que déjame hacer un poco de espacio es
un rectángulo más o menos así que tiene
una división aproximadamente a esta
altura y tiene una línea que parte más o
menos a la mitad algo así y además los
vértices se llaman acá
l m
y tiene ok entonces aquí tenemos esta
figura y lo que nos preguntan es la
razón k n entre m n cuánto es k n entre
m n m n sale entonces los lados que nos
interesan son este de acá estoy acá y
éste acá sale queremos encontrar acá en
entre m n bueno pues vamos a ver que
tenemos de opciones en los incisos en el
inciso 1 lo que nos dicen es que el
perímetro de klm n es 30
no voy a poner así el perímetro de cada
l m n es igual a 30 a lo mejor convenga
pasar esto a cosas que tengan que ver
con kn y mn klm n es un rectángulo de
modo que su perímetro es dos veces este
lado más dos veces este lado bueno es la
suma de todos los lados pero como es un
rectángulo éste es igual a éste y éste
es igual a éste entonces sabemos que dos
veces m n
más dos veces caen es igual a 30 y aquí
podemos dividir entre 2 y nos dice que m
n más kn es igual a 15 pero esto todavía
no es suficiente verdad aquí sabemos
simplemente que esto más esto es 15 pero
queremos la razón que la suma sea 15 no
tendría porqué darnos la razón a lo
mejor éste es muy grande y esto es
pequeño o este lado es muy grande y este
lado es pequeño entonces necesitamos más
información vale vamos a ver qué dice el
inciso 2
en el inciso 2 dice que los tres
rectángulos pequeños tienen las mismas
dimensiones entonces los tres
rectángulos rectángulos pequeños
pequeños tienen las mismas
más dimensiones dimensiones ok a ver
vamos a ver qué significa este así
solito por ejemplo vamos a fijarnos en
este rectángulo y pensemos que este lado
mide x estoy aquí bueno si este lado
mide x como las dimensiones de estos
tres rectángulos son las mismas este
cachito de acá también mide x
este cachito de acá también mide x este
de acá me de equis y los dos de arriba
que no voy a marcar este y este también
miden x vale pero observa esto
automáticamente nos da la medida del
lado largo este lado de acá es 2x y como
los 3 rectángulos tienen las mismas
dimensiones ahora esta altura ya de este
punto a este punto es 2x similarmente de
aquí para acá es 2 x 2 x y kn también
mide 2 x vale y entonces lo que
estábamos buscando era la razón entre kn
y mn y esa ya la podemos calcular porque
como caen es 2x y mn es 3x pues
realmente no nos importa mucho cuanto
sea x sino simplemente que 2x entre 3 x
3 x es igual a 2 tercios y entonces la
información del inciso 2 fue suficiente
por sí misma para responder la pregunta
entonces la respuesta sería b arriba no
respondí cuál era la respuesta me parece
bueno no puse cuál era la respuesta
teníamos que decir utilizar los dos
entonces la respuesta era así
bueno entonces la primera y la segunda
es b vamos al 118 a ver qué dice
problemas 118 110 y 8va
dice que n es un entero positivo n
entero
pero positivo positivo y lo que queremos
determinar es si 150 / n s entero será
cierto que 150 entre n es entero
y se enteró bueno pues vamos a ver qué
opciones nos dan en la opción 1 nos
dicen qué n es menor que 7 esto será
suficiente para ver si 150 entre n se
enteró bueno pues en él se enteró
positivo así que ya no hay mucho mucho
para dónde irse verdad n tiene que ser
uno dos tres cuatro cinco o seis
ok a ver uno divide a 150 pues si 150
entre unos 150 150 entre 12 75 que es
entero éste funciona este funciona 150
entre 350 que también es entero 150
entre 4 a ver vamos a hacer la división
150 entre 44 cabe tres veces 3 por 4 12
12 restamos 15 menos 2 estrés baja el 0
cabe 7 veces 7 por 4 28 restamos y
sobran 2 entonces no 150 no es divisible
entre 4 entonces saber que en es menor
que 7 no es suficiente porque puede que
sí sea entero o puede que no 150 entre
el vamos al inciso 2 en el inciso 2 nos
dice que n
es un número número primo
primo ok si únicamente sabemos que es un
número primo pues no podemos decir gran
cosa verdad por ejemplo n puede ser 2 y
entonces 150 entre n es 75 que si es
entero pero n podría ser un primo más
grande que 150 y entonces ni siquiera
nos quedaría un número mayor que 1
quedaría entre 0 y 1 que él no es entero
entonces simplemente saber que n es
primo no nos dice gran cosa pero
combinando eso con la información uno se
limita bastante n porque en ella no
puede ser 4
y tampoco puede ser 6 ya vimos que 1 2 y
3 se dividen a 150 o sea si nos queda
entero y ya sólo faltaría verificar el 5
y 150 entre 5 es 30 que si es entero
entonces tenemos que en 1 2 3 y 5 que
son los números que corresponden a
combinar los incisos 1 y 2 si nos queda
entero y por lo tanto combinando 1 y 2
sí podemos responder la pregunta y
entonces la respuesta sería si vamos a
dejarle hasta aquí porque ya no me queda
tanto tiempo pero nos vemos en el
próximo vídeo para seguir haciendo de
estos ejercicios